[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosen
B that's my Halloween voice sorry I had
to do it if you're annoyed I'm sorry
it's Halloween so get over it we always
like doing funny goofy things for
Halloween Ryan happy Halloween happy all
Halls Eve to you why can't witches have
babies their husbands have
halloweenies that's my Halloween joke
cuz they're Hollow there's no Sean yeah
yeah yeah no I'm there with you okay
it's not that funny but I get it um we
have a fun episode today for you and uh
just a few things happy Halloween I hope
thanks thanks for letting uh inside of
you be your podcast to listen to I know
there's lots of choices but um hopefully
we're doing something right here we're
having real conversations with real
people celebrities with uh all sorts of
folks it's
exciting uh also the inside of you
online store tons of fun merch lexmas
autograph scripts ship keys from the
show autographed tumblers and uh
sweatshirts inside of you uh lots of
cool stuff go on there there's tons of
stuff and on the tville podcast.com we
have
autographed new artwork Tom and I both
signed it there's only 50 prints get
them while they last on the tovp
podcast.com and last but not least well
before that my band sunspin Suns
spin.com we're trying to do another
stage it so make sure you follow us on
Instagram you can go to my link Tree on
Instagram it's @th Michel
rosenbalm um and the link tree will tell
you all the things I'm doing Cameo and
all the other fun stuff cons going to
Rhode Island and Nashville and it's
going to be a lot of fun so hopefully I
can hug you we can Tom and I will do a
Smallville nights at both those events
and thank you everyone for joining
Patron you guys save the show without
you couldn't do it patreon.com inside
you if you want to support the podcast
and and you can also follow us on our
handles and write a review if you really
want the show to do better Ryan oh @
inside tood on Twitter inside podcast on
Instagram and Facebook that is correct
Our Guest today Ryan is a famous DJ also
done some acting
writing bit of everything a loving man
just a really lovable human being I've
known him for years and um I actually on
his first wave show I I was on that
before he asked me if I want to come on
again I do Richard
this guy talks about his
relationships with other musicians talks
about his career his life it's such a
unique thing he was around at such a
unique time when his career blew up um
you know those 80s those early 80s and
into the MTV era and um you know and he
is still around and still doing a lot of
fun stuff you could listen to him every
week in first wave um let's get inside
of my friend Richard Blade it's my point
of you're listening to inside of you
with Michael Rosen
[Music]
bom inside of you with Michael rosenbom
was not recorded in front of a live
studio audience all right the first
thing this guy does is gets in here and
starts talking about hanging out with
Duran Duran you're were just in Chicago
Richard yeah just go back yesterday one
of my favorite bands one of so many
people love Duran Durant I've seen them
in concert I remember I met Simon Lebon
and I was just like hey I'm a big fan
he's like oh great he's very he's kind
of cold I'm sure you don't know him as
that or do you well the thing is about
being the lead singer of a band everyone
wants you you know even though John is
there and Nick is there and Roger is
there the Press tend to not know about
them the fans do I mean it sounds
ridiculous to say that the Press always
want well we want the sing we want that
Simon guy so he always gets the
questions he always gets the
appointments he always gets the the time
required so sometimes he's so busy he's
like yeah hi well don't you think that
that's uh you know it's part for the
course it's like if you're going to be
the lead singer of a band you're going
to be successful that's what's going to
happen if you're the lead actor in a
movie everybody wants to talk to you
about it exactly but you with with
jandan you know they've always been the
five of them back in the day now the
four of them you know so everyone should
want John as well and everyone should
want Nick and Roger because they're all
loved by the fans but still the Press
don't know that so it's always oh yeah I
want Simon right I hear you but like you
go to Chicago and you talk to Simon oh
well yeah and then Simon said H we're
going out sailing tomorrow do you want
to come no he asked you to go sailing
yeah did you go oh absolutely Chris and
I were on the boat and I I had to hold
my back my myself back cuz I wanted to
ask him to sing Rio while we're on the
boat CU that was the video the music
video absolutely but he did wear the
striped t-shirt and if you go to my
social media there's pictures all over
it I didn't post them till yesterday
because I was thinking no I shouldn't do
that but then they posted them on their
social media and had this shot of me and
Simon and then a picture of me chatting
with Roger and he goes 24-hour contest
what's Richard Blade and Roger Taylor
talking about so uh you know people
write in and put their posts up Jesus
man that's a dream that's like to me if
I was on a boat with Duran Duran I think
life had you know that was it that'd be
it for me it was great and when I got
back from chatting with Roger because
Christ and I kind of just did our own
thing Christa said oh I was just uh with
wife his lovely wife and uh Simon was
reading poetry to me wait a minute Simon
Leon from Duran Duran what was he saying
he was reading different poems saw you
standing by them exactly he was doing it
amazing I know I you have lived a
Charmed Life I mean you really have and
also a lot of people I mean I've never
interviewed someone who's done what you
do what you've done uhhuh I mean it
seems like you know becoming an actor is
just it's so hard and there's just a
small percentage of people there's so
many more talented people that don't
make it than the ones that do and like
the amount of work I mean did you know
you were going get into this what what
were you thinking as a child I mean you
eventually went to Oxford and you're a
smart guy and all this but like with
your family what were you thinking you
were going to get into I didn't know I
wanted to do something um I wanted to
write for a long time when I was a kid I
wrote a
spec script for Doctor Who oh wow did
you watch that show oh I love people
love that freaking show Doctor there's
so many people listen listening that so
you wrote a spec script for Doctor Who
yeah and I sent it into the BBC and
heard nothing back it was like crickets
but doctor who gives a [__] Richard yeah
but exactly but you know unsolicited
manuscripts etc etc they probably
dropped it straight into the trash can
but I always wanted to uh write and then
I got into college and my one of the
roommates we had in the dorm was the
college DJ and he was a great guy Norm
Holmes but he was not particularly
good-looking or anything like that but I
noticed when he was DJing all the girls
got around him and I thought oh that's
not a bad thing to do you know so you
did it at first for the girls oh well
absolutely okay isn't that why anyone
gets into music or any form of
entertainment way the thought of thought
is hey you know I I you know cuz I was
always I never got girls I was I was not
attractive I was the smallest kid in my
high school I never went on dates never
went to dances and so all of a sudden
when I started I did a play and people
were like oh you're funny I'm like wait
a minute yeah what what's this about I'm
getting attention I need attention were
you a little bit of an attention [__]
like me absolutely absolutely and as
soon as the people I wasn't the captain
of the rugby I actually I was the
captain of the swim team but really yeah
but it was very uh a very big change
when I started DJing suddenly all the
girls were around and it was like like
wow this is kind of very cool I was I
was warming up for Norm because he was
in the third year and I was in the first
year right and so what was he playing
what kind of music what year is it take
us back okay this would be oh my God
it's way back this would be like
1972 wow the year of my birth there you
go you don't you look good well thank
you thanks and uh nor we'd be playing
lots of things like free all right now
was the
that was the
floor yes and some other Rock like Deep
Purple Smoke on the
Water oh yeah yeah and Northern soul and
Northern Soul was American R&B that was
imported into the UK and it was a very
fast uptempo uh beat and people love
that as well and I loved it as well and
Bowie was big as well suffragette City
wham bam thank you ma'am that packed the
floor and I noticed that and I I kind of
tried to read the crowd and Norm said
after a few weeks he said do you want to
do like the first hour and I said sure
So I would play the first hour and then
he goes you want to do like the first
two hours of a 4H hour gig because it
was his last year and he wasn't and you
started getting good from this
experience yeah I mean it's part of the
hund you know the 10,000 hours thing
right and so uh I was playing the music
and making sure the crowd was dancing
but staying away from some of the big
songs that Norm would play so I didn't
want to step on his toes and when he was
leaving College he said you should take
over at a DJ and so uh the next year I
came in and they made me part of the
social club you know and the college DJ
and it just took off from there and it
just took off from there and the thing
was we rented the gear every weekend at
10 a time you know $15 by then and so I
said to them you know this is a bit
silly that we're paying this money why
don't we buy some gear and that way we
don't have to pay out the money and they
said well how much would it cost and I
said I'd looked in the uh trades ahead
of time and I said it' be about £300 and
we'd have our own gear so in 30 weeks it
would be paid for and they went that
makes sense uh can you buy it for us and
I said yeah so I said I'm going to go
down to London and I'll buy it and have
it shipped up here and so I went down to
um the end of our hill we were on North
Hinkley Hill and there was a the
motorway going through the freeway for
all the Americans uh the motorway going
through and I stood there and hitchhiked
down to London and I was there for about
10 minutes and this Mini Cooper ass
pulls up this guy says where you going I
said I'm going down to London I'm going
down uh just off oxa Street to um
Tottenham Court Road to pick up that's
where all the electronic stores were
yeah to pick up some gear and he goes oh
hop in I'll drive you I've got a store
on uh Oxford Street and so I jump in and
he goes so what's your name I goes
Richard and he goes oh Richard too and
that's it wasn't Richard Blade then no
no it's Richard Shephard Richard Rich
there you go and uh so we're we're
driving down to London and he said what'
you do I'm a DJ you know he goes okay
great he goes I Got This Record Store
and everyone tries to sell their
independent uh labels and local bands
through my store because HMV won't and
wh Smiths won't but I will and he said
and I figured I should buy like a little
recording studio and that way the bands
could not only make the music but then
they could sell it in my store and he
said but I can't afford anything in
London the prices are crazy but up here
in Oxford uh there's a lot of places I
can buy uh that I've looked at and I
found this this is a random guy that you
just gave you a ride into London yeah
picked me up but he said I wanted to
pick up a hitchhiker cuz I I was so
excited to tell him I think I found
finally found a place you know this was
before cell phones or anything and he he
was excited to tell someone that all
these weeks and months have looking for
a place he'd found it he goes I found
this Farm that's great and I'm going to
turn it into a recording studio and it's
actually got enough rooms that people
could stay there and I said that's great
and he goes and I'm I'm going to you
know be able to put some of the bands
that want to make music there they could
stay for the weekend and it's it's going
to be fantastic is it do did this become
something big well yeah it did kind of
you might have heard of the guy I knew
it was coming I knew it was coming so he
was great and he goes this is my record
store points to it and he goes but totam
court roads another mile and a half down
I'm going to drive you all way there and
I go oh thank you man that's so nice of
you and so we drove past uh his record
store Virgin records and we went down to
to Court Road wait did you just fly over
the word Virgin Records yeah yeah I did
okay keep going so Richard drops me off
and he goes well best of luck man and I
go best of luck with the the farm and so
that was the start for Richard Bron yeah
I know wait wait wait this is a random
hitchhiker he picked up was you yeah and
so are you still friends well not
friends but fast forward to uh
2005 and he was on love line and Christ
and I were driving back from the king's
head in Santa Monica I've done love line
and I went you know I should stop by and
say hello so I pulled off and went over
to Calver City where they were doing
love line from because they were doing
it I think it was on Premier Network
when you just started first wave yeah I
was just just come back from the
Caribbean and I wasn't with krock or
anything anymore but uh i' left on great
terms with them I was friends with every
great friends with Drew and uh with Adam
so so I thought oh I'll pop in and you
know see if I can say hi to Richard
Branson so on the very first break they
go yeah go you know come and say hi to
Richard Branson so he comes out all long
blond hair and everything I told him the
story and he goes I don't remember you
but I remember picking up a hitchhiker
so that was you and I said yeah and he
goes I just had to tell someone about it
I was so excited come here and he gives
me a hug and he goes so good to see you
again so I I looked at him and I said so
how did it work out for
[Laughter]
you inside you is brought to you by
neurohacker qualia senolytic let me tell
you guys I've talked about this for a
while they have been a sponsor and what
I like about it is they stick around
because uh I speak the truth this stuff
really has helped me my brain is less
foggy I have more energy these are
things that have worked for me and I was
taking this product before they were a
sponsor so there uh have you guys heard
about senolytics it's a class of
ingredients discovered less than 10
years ago and they're being called one
of the biggest discoveries of our time
for helping to promote healthy aging
helping to enhance your physical
prime uh your life goals in your career
and Beyond require productivity but
let's be honest the aging process is not
our friend and it comes to endless
energy and productivity look guys if
someone would have told me that there
are science-backed ingredients that
could help me feel 15 years younger in a
matter of months I would not have
believed it then I tried quaa cenotic as
we age everyone accumulates Cent cells
in their body Cent cells may cause
symptoms of Aging such as aches and pain
slow workout recoveries sluggish mental
and physical energy associated with that
middle-age feeling that I feel
constantly until now also known as
zombie cells they are old and worn out
and not serving a useful function for
our health anymore but they could be
taking up space and nutrients from our
healthy cells much like pruning the
yellowing and Dead Leaves off a plant
qualia senolytic helps remove those worn
out Cent cells to allow for the rest of
them to thrive in the body and I just
take two times a month I take it two
times a month the formula is non-GMO
vegan gluten-free and the ingredients
are meant to complement one another
factoring in the combined effect of all
ingredients together and Ryan it has 100
day money guarantee well money back
guarantee if you don't like it to me
when a product does that it's no BS they
know their product works and like I said
I've been taking this product long
before they were our sponsor and I was
really excited when I found out they
were our sponsor um but my energy levels
are higher I I definitely feel a lot
younger I'm more productive I don't know
how you don't see that even when I did
that live podcast don't you think I was
on fire oh absolutely fire fire man uh
Ryan let me just tell you what makes the
quala brand unique fully transparent
formulas no proprietary ingredients
formulas created by top scientists MDS
and NDS science-backed formulas backed
with hundreds of research citations
powerful results thousands of real life
changing reviews over six years and
counting read the website and 100 day
moneyback guarantee zero Financial Risk
to try any quala formula it's all there
help resist aging at the cellular level
tried qualia senolytic go to neurohacker
dcom inside for up to $100 off and use
code inside at checkout for an
additional 15% off these statements have
not been evaluated by the Food and Drug
Administration the products and
statements are not intended to diagnose
treat cure or prevent any disease that's
neurohacker dcom inside for an extra 15%
off your purchase thanks to neurohacker
for sponsoring today's episode today's
sponsor new sense.com uses a CGM right
here under my arm which is a small
device that provides realtime feedback
on how your body responds to the foods
that you're eating your exercise stress
and even your sleep now this is
something that look guys if you see I'm
wearing it I am wearing my glucose
monitor because I have found out I'm I'm
gonna get into this so just give me a
second uh Nutri sense really monitors my
glucose levels so when I find my myself
crashing
tired you can just take your phone CU
there's an app I put it under my arm the
sensor retrieves all the information and
it shows my glucose levels for the last
x amount of hours and I go wow I spiked
here well that's cuz you had three root
beers dude maybe you shouldn't be having
so much root beer maybe you should keep
your glucose levels at a even place so
you feel healthier you feel better you
have more energy
um you know it's not just for people who
are you know I guess diabetic or
whatever it's for people who want to
live a healthier life and that's what's
happened to me I didn't know what this
was and neutri sense changed my mind on
this whole uh outlook on on on health um
Nutri sense helps you analyze your
glucose levels in real time in response
to food exercise stress and sleep Nutri
sense includes one month of free board
certified nutritionist guidance and
support uh it really is awesome Ryan if
you want me to get you one um you could
your your life
it's it shows you what you're eating and
and and what you're doing you can
monitor all that you take notes on this
and it's just so easy to say okay I
remember I crashed I was really tired at
2 o'clock why well right here it says
well you spiked and you crashed and this
is why this happens and if you're if you
like if you work and you doing all these
things you need more energy you monitor
your
glucose and it's just amazing my
nutritionist helped me interpret the
data and promptly answered all my
questions Patrick thank you Patrick over
at Nutri sense I said well what are
these see how it spikes here and spikes
here well well what exactly are you
eating and drinking Michael and they you
know we managed it and I said well
what's what are better things I could
have in my diet that I can get some some
energy but won't crash and so he sent me
a list of things so it really is
wonderful and in just the short time
that I've done this I've noticed better
sleep I've noticed uh sustained energy
less brain fog it's because I'm not
doing eating all those bad things I'm
not having all that sugar and it's
really helped me and you know I'm 51 and
I no matter how old you are you want to
have sustained energy throughout the day
and right now visit nutrients.com
inside to save $30 and get one month of
free nutritionist support that's neutr
sense.com
inside and he laugh and he couldn't
believe it and then I said could I get a
photograph with you and he goes
absolutely and he goes um could my wife
as well I said she's you know obviously
a huge fan of yours and he goes come on
and he picks up Christa in his arms like
that and we got this picture of him just
standing there with a long hair and I
thought this is a guy who really
deserved the success because a nice guy
nice guy I know that all the employees
of Virgin Air loved him he looked after
the ladies and the pilots and everything
and really took care of the passengers
and you know he had virgin bride going
on in England as well I mean he was just
a he is just an incredibly smart guy
what differentiated you from all the
other DJs because you were able to make
the the cross over the Atlantic into the
states and become this household name
and join krock and do all these things
interview these big bands I've read
something where you said you were sort
of the
conduit you were the conduit to all the
the British singers and all these you
know to to sort of um give the American
people what's going on the information
of what's going on overseas and the the
music music that's over there yeah I've
always tried to be um on top of what's
Happening one of the things that the
local BBC that I work for for a very
short time when I was in Oxford it was
BBC Radio Oxford they had a sign up that
said engage Brain before putting mouth
into gear in other words know what you
were going to talk about and the other
one was if you've got nothing to say
don't say anything and so I've always
figured that if you've got nothing to
say Don't just give the time and the
temperature and the name of the song
know a little about it the audience
deserves that and so I've always
believed that whether it was working
live or working on the radio and when I
was working in Europe I toured Europe
for two and a half years in the clubs
before I came over to America and I
really wanted to get into radio and when
I was in Austria um working at this club
called Magic this guy came up and he
said hey you know I have a radio station
that I run called UT a AA 3 which have
you ever heard of that band with the
Austrian F yeah F yeah and we go D yeah
though they they're actually Welsh are
they Welsh and they became Underworld
the EDM band oh my God and they wanted
to screw around with DJs so they came up
with an unpronouncable name this was
long before Prince became symbol man
right you know so they came out with f r
e u
r so ladies and gentlemen right now I'd
like to play your song
from but D do was you're absolutely
right brilliant brilliant so I I was
working in Europe and I got the taste
for radio again when I was uh went on
utry and I was there for two months
every Friday night doing a rock program
and I thought this is great and but the
thing was I was a novelty act I was an
English person speaking in English on a
German language radio station and I
thought I got to go somewhere where
where they speak English and there was
hardly any radio happening in England I
mean unless you were one of the six DJs
on BBC Radio 1 you weren't getting
anywhere right and so that was so
there's not really wasn't really a lot
of money to be made no well decent money
if you got onto BBC Radio one but that
was it that that was the only only gig
on the whole in the whole country and so
I thought okay I make a list there's
America there's Canada there's South
Africa there's Australia and there's New
Zealand they all speak English one of
those countries so I put the put it in
order shuffled it around America number
one Australia number two New Zealand
number three Canada number four only
because it's so cold in Canada love
Canada love Canadian people as well one
of my favorite countries they don't get
mad in Canada no they don't I just did a
gig in Kingsville Ontario uh two weeks
ago loveliest people in the world oh my
God fantastic yeah and South Africa was
number five just because of all the
racial problems there I don't think I
could work in a country particularly
then that was aarth you know whites over
here blacks over there I just could not
put up with that so but America was your
top Cho was Top Choice and then LA
because Hollywood and sunshine blue
skies California Girls you know that was
the whole thing because I've always
liked ladies and um yes you as as your
book World in my eyes States yeah so I I
flew yeah I flew over to LA and um for
four years couldn't get arrested so I
went back to dejing in clubs and doing
mobile discos and stuff like that and uh
I went kept going to every radio station
in town and they all said uh sorry you
know can't have you it's not going to
work but thank you very much for your
tape the worst was when I went to kme
and at the time I'd been doing gigs i'
done a a real real lucky gig I was asked
by a event coordinator to do a gig for
their client and would I meet their
client first and would I Caravan behind
her to the car the client's house so I
said okay and I followed her and uh we
went up to malibo and we turned off just
by Paradise Cove and went up the canyon
and she goes this is Barbara this is
Richard no not Barbara strian exactly
are you kidding me Barbara strian she
was my first big big gig that I did and
it was her son's bar mitzvah for uh
Jason gold the son of Elliot and and
Barbara and she put on this in she was
the nicest person everyone said
afterwards oh God yeah she's such a
[__] and all this kind of stuff she
couldn't have been nice if you show up
and do your job she treated you like
gold the waitress who served me my food
was Barbara stren I mean couldn't have
been nicer and she had everyone now I
mean David geffin was there Neil Diamond
was there were you Star Struck not by
her because I didn't didn't play her
music much I was in the clubs at the
time if it had been Anita Ward who was
there you could Ring My Bell but also
didn't she had that song and we got
nothing to be guilty of that a little
disco yeah a little disco and um that
she you don't bring me flowers with Neil
Diamond I play that in the ballad
section but obviously I knew who she was
I knew she was one of the biggest
singers in the world but there were so
many other people there um Larry Hagman
was there and so yeah and that was the
great thing he enjoyed the party so much
he took one of my business cards and
then I did the party at his house for
the r party for season one of Dallas so
wait a minute you started doing so
people Word of Mouth are you saying Word
of Mouth Word of Mouth Richard Blade
he's the guy dick dick Shephard at the
time dick Shephard and then you saw a
movie Ryan you might have heard of this
called Blade Runner no well I saw it
advertised you know cuz the whole thing
was I did all these parties and then I
did did one for zajak Gabor oh yeah and
that was up in the the hills on one of
the stilt houses right and there were
two people there that I was just
thrilled to meet one of them was my
all-time favorite movie actor and I'd
never met him before and the amazing
thing was I met him again two weeks
later never never again who he came up
to me I I I saw him and I said that you
know could I tell you something kind of
weird and he said why what and I said
I I went to school with a wet underarm
because of you for about 3 weeks and he
why would that be and I said because my
James Bond water pistol shoulder holster
kept leaking and he goes you know I had
one of those as well I used to collect
all of the memorabilia from the Bond
movie Sean Conor I know and he was
incredible it was every you see you're
meeting your Heroes and they're nice but
that's rare and they were everything you
wanted them to be that's he he looked
like met a lot of [__] Rich I've met
a lot of [__] you know if he looked
like if he punched you you were going
down he looked guy a real man he he
looked like
bond this show is sponsored by better
help Ryan you ever feel like your brain
is getting in the way of living your
best life all the time yeah I would say
so like you know what you should do
what's good for you but you you just
can't seem the do it oh yeah yeah
therapy helps you figure out what's
holding you back so your brain can work
for you instead of against you and this
is what happens with um therapy you're
you have all these things bottled up and
you need to let them out and you need to
talk to a professional it really really
helps therapy is a great way to learn
positive coping skills and how to set
boundaries it empowers you to be the
best version of yourself and it's way
more convenient with better help it's
entirely online and designed to be
convenient flexible and suited to your
skill schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire it took me like a minute
it's so easy even I can do it then you
get matched with a licensed therapist
switch therapists anytime for no
additional charge seriously it's not
uncommon you meet someone you're like no
I want to try someone else it's easy
just like that betterhelp is truly the
best way to make your brain your friend
give it a try visit betterhelp.com
inside today to get 10% off your first
month that's better help h
lp.com
SL
inside and the other person I was
downstairs in the game room while
everyone was upstairs eating and they
cleared out the pool table and
everything I put in my DJ gear so I'm
sitting there just kicking back doing
nothing and this little guy comes in and
comes up to me and he says uh could I
could I go through your records please
and I I said sure of course you can I
want to guess this one and he he looks
through his the records and I said you
know I I had the new victory album they
they didn't mail it to me he goes you do
could you could you play could you put
it on cuz we're getting ready for the
tour and so I said anything that you
want to hear and he goes yeah shake
shake your body down to the ground he
said I'm getting the dance dance routine
down so he gets out and he start I put
it on and he starts dancing to it and
I'm like wow and he he goes can you play
it again I said yeah and he goes you
have a cassette player and I said I I do
absolutely I'm not I can't do an
impression of him so I'm not going to
try and I said absolutely and he goes I
I just came from the studio with Quincy
so I got not Michael Jackson Michael
Jackson and he goes out to his limo and
he comes in with a cassette and he goes
we just put this together today and so I
I play it for him and he stop stop stop
he goes play that part again I go okay
he go stop stop stop can can you play it
again and then when I point to you turn
it up loud I said okay so I play it
again Turn It Up loud and he goes horns
aren't loud enough horns aren't loud
enough on that I got to tell Quincy the
horns aren't loud enough and so I'm
listening and he's playing I'm playing
rock rock with you or I can't remember
which one Don't Stop Till You Get Enough
from his album H but he was just on top
of the music he was listening to every
single he obsessed yeah he but but
focused he wasn't one of these artists
that let any other people do it for him
and then he would get out there and
dance to this song and I'm like wow you
know cuz I grew up the Jackson 5 and he
wasn't Michael Jackson at the time he
was just a member of The Jackson 5 and I
this was a band that had saved my ass so
many times no as DJ and you know put on
Dancing Machine the floor you know and
uh one bad you know One Bad Apple don't
spoil the whole bunch of girl and all
this kind of stuff and ABC I loved all
that music and then um afterwards he
took my card and he said would you do
some parties for me and I said sure So I
go to his house on havenhurst in Nino
I've been there yeah yeah and I I djed
about 12 parties for Michael Jackson did
he pay well he paid well and then I I
did the uh launch party for the tour and
I had to get be screened by the FBI so
I'm glad I had a green card at the time
because uh the Jackson 5 and myself were
and it was the Jacksons but they did the
S like a five cuz they left mown and
gone to Epic uh we were all in the um
bank vault of this bank that was on
Wilshire Boulevard and now it's like a
clothing store you s laon but right
across from The Beverly walshire Hotel
and the idea was we were in the bank
vault and they were breaking out of the
bank vault and they had Entertainment
Tonight there and all the TV cameras and
then I had my fog machine so they of
course you did yeah and they they tried
to put give us a walkie-talkie but the
vault door was too thick for the radio
signal but the they weren't locking the
door so it was opened slightly so we had
an XLR cable go through and when they
gave me the signal it was 30 seconds
before they would open the vault door
and that's when I dropped the dry ice
into the fog machine fill the thing with
fog turn my one laser on back then it
was just a red dot just like you know
like pong back in the early days going
up and down it was just a red laser
going through the and they open the
thing and the fog came out and the
Jacksons came dancing through it so it
was and I was having a great time were
you seeing any like uh you know you're
at all these parties and you're you're
you're DJing all these parties and all
these huge celebrities are saying hey
you have a card and calling you and
you're making the rounds and becoming a
name right did you see a lot of drug use
did you see a lot of Darkness did you
see a lot of craziness oh I saw a lot of
craziness in the fact that there were a
lot of women there going after the
artists but the drug who's the bigger
one with the with the
women well the Jacksons always attracted
a lot they always had tons of women
going now yeah and Neil Diamond actually
at Barbara str's party there was a lot
of hangers on going up trying to get
close to Neil because he was a lot
younger did he like it he didn't really
give him any time of day you know he was
kind of pushing him away gosh NE but I
was getting all this publicity and I got
the front page of the Los Angeles time a
picture of DJing with the Jacksons
behind and I I was thrilled with that so
I put this whole uh package together
with an audition tape and all my press
cuttings and the fact I'd done radio in
England and in Austria and I went back
out to the radio stations and again they
shot me down all of them all of them
shot me down and the worst one was
kme they say anything I pass to this I
said look I just finished this starting
off the Jackson's tour and its front
page and everything like that and I so
I'm willing to do anything you know I
I'll work overnight for a month for free
just so you can hear me uh you know you
tell me what what I can do and the
program director was female and she
pushed everything back at me and she
said you'll never work in this town with
that accent and then just turned around
and just didn't even want to talk what
what was her name do you remember I'm
not going to say Sam's name she had a
guy's name but I ran into her three
years later after my talk after and he
said [__] you I I was Sam I didn't
actually I she came up to me and uh she
was uh had been Let Go by kme actually
was since 87 and so I was really peing
and she came out to me and it was doing
a grand opening in Beverly Hills and she
goes gosh you've been doing so well
haven't you and I said yeah what are you
doing now she said well I'm not in radio
at the moment I'm I'm a
secretary and I looked at her and I went
oh no but you'll you'll do well you'll
do well success just being nice about it
you don't need had to hold it back I
just wanted to cuz things turned around
for you quickly cuz I've never forgotten
that to this day cuz I walked out of K
uh and was this 1981 no this was
19 end of 79 79 and I walked out and it
was metromedia square and I walked out
onto the boulevard there and I looked up
at the sign at the k that was written on
the antenna and I was like [__] you one
of these days I am going to get into
radio and um I'll show you and then uh K
West which is now power 1059 K West um
they were having a contest for the best
unknown DJ and so then you had to send
in a 10-minute tape so I put one
together and at the end of the 10-minute
tape I did a remix of Pink Floyd's
Another Brick In thewall which I made
just using a real to real you know still
have it no I I could I could do it again
so much easier now yeah take 10 minutes
now cuz it's digital you know and I
could do 40 tracks but then I was
working with a two track it took you
days days and days like I I thought
either they're going to throw that in
the trash because it's you know Pink
Floyd you know who's messing with Pink
Floyd or they're going to like it and
they actually played it on the air and
then they said instead of one winner we
have two winners for the best unknown DJ
and they picked two winners and I was
one of the two and got
$110,000 you needed that no I didn't I I
was doing well but I I'm not going to
say no to it and I got the most
important thing I got an hour on the air
with JJ Jackson who went over totv a
year and a half later with K West with K
West right and he again couldn't have
been nicer he goes play whatever you
want and i' put together a playlist
knowing what they liked you know so
there was AC DC in their brand new um
track called You Shook Me All Night Long
oh my God yeah and 38 special and vans
like that so you played one hour I
played one hour and that went off with
Gang Busters and that went off great uh
my girlfriend at home taped it for me
but JJ taped it he taped the whole show
and he gave me also a skim tape which
was only my voice and the first three
seconds of music because that's what you
send into a radio station cuz they know
the songs they don't want to sit through
Ryan didn't know any of this [__] I
don't think I knew any of this and so I
sent that tape out and I sent it to San
Diego to Santa Barbara to San Francisco
to Bakersfield and two days after I sent
it out I got a call from Bakersfield
saying uh we'd like you to come out
because I think we want to work with you
and I said okay so I drove out to
Bakersfield to Magic 98 and it was a
hard rock station and they said we want
to hire you as the nighttime guy from uh
6 to midnight and the music director and
I'm like holy [__] the music I'm disco
dick and they want
me they want me to program a hard rock
station and I said so what's the deal
and they said well throughout the day we
get harder at night we really rock so we
rock so hard at night you can't play
Stairway to Heaven that's too mellow and
I said so what's the criteria for me
adding music and they took out Ted Nan's
double live Gonzo album and they dropped
the needle in the middle of Wang Dang
Sweet pun tang and they said that's as
mellow as we get wow and I said okay
I'll I'll do it for a year it was my
goal radio so I was at KAC and so I went
back to DJing in clubs before I did the
overnight was I DJ in a club from 8
until 11: and then on the air from
midnight till 6:00 at K and one of the
clubs uh La Hawk Club in um enino they
decided they were going to buy
commercial time to advertise it because
it was going well and I was playing this
crossover music that was just coming in
called New Wave that my dad was sending
me from England and it was getting busy
and so they said well we're going to
appetize it said well kyc plays new wave
and they said no he got no signal can't
be heard in the valley we're going to
advertise on this other station called
krock so um you were the first person to
play new wave at kro one one of the
first I mean k krro was playing it but I
was playing in the clubs so they said
will you go and do the spot at kro the
commercial because otherwise we have to
pay their DJs like $500 to voice the
spot right if you do it we save 500
bucks because we're not going to pay you
anything so I said yeah sure you know
because it just brings the crowd in for
me and keeps my job going so I I went to
K Rock and I cut the commercial and um
the program director the production
director it was really funny so casual I
just walk into the production room I
said I'm here to cut commercial okay go
on in production director there John
logic and he said oh you're going to cut
commercial okay I'll go for lunch I'll
be back walks out all this gears there I
could have been Joe blow off the street
you know walking out with teak recorders
but I cut the commercial put it onto a c
labeled it I copied the way they did
their labels and everything he came back
he goes ah it was really good that's
that's great thank you so much so the
spot starts airing and the Morning Show
which was randoo and Evans heard it and
they said oh who's the English guy
he should do some drops for us so I came
back out and I did these drops for um go
to bed with April she was a nighttime
girl real good-look she'd been in
Playboy and everything you slept with
her oh no I didn't I I I I I would have
but no I'd try not to at work I said go
to bed with April wake up with Rondo and
Evans now then all the jocks wanted me
to do drops and then they these other
clients of sales uh the sales people
wanted the English accent so I started
doing commercials all over krock so now
I'm on KAC but my voice is all over
krock and then I get a call you've got
to meet with the program director of
krock and I thought oh God he's going to
pull everything and tell me I can't do
it so I walk in and he said we're doing
this um holiday vacation in Hawaii and I
did this deal with the DJs if they could
sell 20 spots they go as well because
krock had no money
and they couldn't afford to give the DJs
paid vacations right but if they could
sell 20 spots on a plane to Hawaii they
could get two weeks off and he said so
it's sold out so we're getting local
celebrities in to cover the uh the air
shifts we've got elvar coming in we got
Danny Elfman coming in from Oingo Boingo
he's going to be Moscow Eddie we got
Mike NES from uh social D coming in but
we got this open spot from 9: to noon
and we need someone and we figured you'd
be a good novelty because you've got an
English accent would you do
it I said yeah two weeks that sounds
great because
but I can't pay you I said that's fine
and you have to quit
KAC because I can't have you on both boy
that's a test he's testing you okay I
said are you going to Hawaii and he goes
I know where you're going with this he
said
here's the deal it's taken me a year and
a half to put this staff together and
we're the Saturday Night Live of radio
he said there isn't a bad shift every
one of my DJs is exactly where they
should be and they're great he said
they're all going to have a job when
they come back and I'm afraid I won't
have a position for you and I looked at
him and I said Rick when you hear me on
the air you'll give me a
job and he said okay and so I I I went I
went on the air I quit k& and I loved
K&C so much and the people there nor
McBride the morning guy and Jimmy
Christopher the the uh program director
I didn't want to steal any audience from
did because they had a little only a
little signal so I changed my name from
dick Shepard and I didn't know what to
call myself and even I went on the air
that day and I still didn't know what to
call myself and I'm flipping desperately
through the Los Angeles Times and I see
Robert Hilburn the critic and I'm like
Richard Hilburn now no no and I wanted
to go back to Richard from dick Richard
hbert no no that's not going to work
it's as bad as Richard shephard I want
something else and I see Blade Runner is
going to open in two weeks didn't know
what the movie was about no one knew it
hadn't opened yet it was going to open
in two weeks time so I Richard Blade
that would work great so I this where
newspapers were yay big right so I drop
it on the floor and the song's finishing
and I come on the air and I go uh that
was flock of sea gos and
telecommunication but the fans call it
Telecom uh by the way this is not Jed
the fish this is me I'm sitting in for
Jed the fish he's in Hawaii right now my
name is and I'd forgotten because I was
so panicked that everyone in everyone in
La was listening and I looked down and
the papers folded oh I was going to call
myself Richard Runner sorry oh cuz Blade
Runner blade Richard Runner and I was
going to steal the RR of Rolls-Royce I
thought that would be a great thing you
know and all that you forgot yeah but I
forgot and I looked down and it's folded
and it just says blade and I went I'm
Richard Blade and this is OMD
electricity and I started the song and I
went oh Richard Blade I guess I'm stuck
with that so that's how that came and
that was it and you worked for krock for
how many years 18 I worked for 18 years
I gave my notice in February of uh 2000
because Chris and I were using Y2K as
the out we bought a house in St Martin
in 1997 were you burned out at that
point I was I wasn't really burnt out I
just wanted to do something different I
grew up in the south of England I always
love scuba diving I used to make my own
wet suits and stuff like that but uh the
water in England is cold even cold even
air is cold everything's cold and uh
it's not that clear on a good day maybe
I could see my hand at the end of my arm
you know underwater I wanted to teach
scuba in the clearest warmest water
wanted to retire yeah and you weren't
old well from Radio yeah well I wasn't
even 50 you know it's in my that's a big
step to just say hey I'm leaving krock
and I I want to just retire and and go
to the or at least go to the Caribbean
or whatever but what what if I didn't do
it then when am I going to do it because
we're all you know on the one way
Direction you know we're all going to
yeah unfortunately you can't go back in
time and I'd done everything I wanted to
do I'd done mornings in La I'd done a
syndicated radio show I'd done half a
dozen movies I'd done TV both hosting
and acting and I was a crappy actor I
was no Lex Luthor I'll tell you that but
you were done I I I was done and I I
thought not because I didn't like kro
but because I wanted to do something
different I wanted to experience it
because my biggest nightmare would be ly
waking up one day and seeing White Tiles
above my head
and a bunch of leads and cords and drips
going into my arms and then going why
didn't I try that you know you don't
usually regret things now you're getting
somewhere now you're getting somewhere I
think that's the you know we talk about
that a lot is like we all have a purpose
and sometimes I mean a lot of times you
have to find your purpose and one thing
is I think people we we get we have jobs
and sometimes we're like oh we're making
money and we're making a living and
we're paying for the bills but I think
it's so important whether you're making
money at it or not to find something you
love that passion on the side that
something that you can do that just
keeps the fires burning the fire inside
you burning and and so you know I I
commend you because it's that's a big
step to just say hey you know I I've got
Now's the Time I'm still young and I'm
going to change gears and I'm going to
do I'm I'm going to take off for a while
and and reinvent myself it was something
I had to do it was and if you have to do
it
you just rip yourself apart inside
because you're regretting why didn't I
try that you know yeah and you yeah it's
like seeing that hot blonde on a Friday
night if you don't go up to her and say
something you regret it all all day
Saturday or you regret asking her and
then she says [__] off but but at least
one or the other at least you gave it a
go at least you tried yeah yeah um you
became really famous during this time
with krock it was like the biggest
station out there you're doing this new
wave you're doing music you love you're
introducing um you know one of the
biggest music scenes in the in the world
to a British music New Wave Music
alternative music and in doing so you
were sort of like I said before the
conduit did you did you you formed Rel
huge relationships I mean I saw an
interview where you're you know after
Andrew Fletcher of the PES mode passed
away and uh God Rest his soul you you uh
you knew him and you know you were
texting with Martin Gore who wrote All
the mode songs and still does and and
he's texting you right back and you have
this relationship with so many people
and you know you you dated the beautiful
Terry nun from Berlin take my breath
away and you had a passionate
relationship with her um all these
relationships were you did you ever get
to a point where you mixed up in drugs
were you mixed up in the scene were you
drinking a lot did you always have a
good head on your shoulders or were you
uh were you enjoying it like everybody
else and getting in too much getting too
deep I never
did drugs I drank I two times I mean I
did cocaine twice uh I never with
who one time uh it was with a record
company geek and uh a couple of bands in
Riverside the other time I was doing TV
show called mv3 and we at one point had
the Psychedelic Furs there on stage and
100 dancers and the Psy delic Furs this
was in June and the sun was baking that
June of 1983 okay they done their
soundcheck and for an hour they were
just standing on stage and the dancers
were Milling around and the floor
manager finally said to me goes if we
don't roll tape we're going to lose the
band he said we got to do something I
said well why isn't he rolling tape the
guy upstairs you know the producer he
says [__] you know what he's like he
said go you go up and I walk in and to
me in hindsight and I'm sure it wasn't
this big there was a mound of coke like
in Scarface on his desk but I'm sure
it's probably fist size but to me it was
you know small Everest and next to it a
snubnose 38 because the teamsters have
been coming around repossessing some of
the cameras and they'd already taken out
the crane right and so uh I said we have
to roll tape or we lose the band and he
goes listen daddy cuz he's and his vocal
tick everyone was Daddy listen Daddy
I'll roll tape if you do a line with me
I said I can't do that I said I got to
be on camera he goes you need it it'll
make you better I'm like if I do a line
will you roll tape and he said I'll roll
it if you do a line so I said okay he
gets this I don't know 520 whatever it
was rolled up he does a sniff first so I
go down and do it and I'm like I I'm
expecting ring rain bows and unicorns
and all I get is I'm grinding my back
teeth cuz I'm naturally hyper anyway
right okay let's roll tape he goes do
another line I said that wasn't the deal
you said I'd do a line and we'd roll
tape and he go why don't you get the
[__] out of here and you tell them to
roll tape yourself you can do that right
and I went okay and I went down I said
all right roll tape and then from then
on it was me and a guy called Peter faer
you know I think you metet yeah that
would call all the rolls because uh the
producer director didn't do it and two
months later the show went off the air
but she Jesus but you never really I
mean look you got into bands reunited
you helped them which was one of my
favorite shows where they find members
of the band and they get them back
together for maybe one last show and
some of those bands actually continued
playing for a while to this day ABC
Drama Berlin drama Berlin uh yeah who
else flock of seagull as well he ended
up touring most by himself but um you've
done so much you've written so many
you've written like seven books yeah
you're getting a Hollywood star of Fame
in a year you get there's a Richard
Blade day that just happened which was
emotional and you were in the in the
courtroom and they gave you the thing
and you were like you know I mean can
you believe I mean when you look back at
all the things you did and a lot of
times I say it's like sort of happen
stance or it's luck as a commodity of
preparation meets opportunity and sort
of that's how my life was I was like
this and I go oh yeah oh well okay and
then somebody remembers you and then you
get something and then that something
leads to something or nothing and it's
just sort of like you just hang around
and you keep going and it seems like
you've worked so hard to get where you
are and you continue to work hard and
your work is so important to you do you
now look back and if you were under
those um you know in that hospital room
with all the things hooked up to you
would you say hey I've lived a great
life this is this is what I've wanted to
do and I've lived my dreams yes I would
I mean we all have minor regrets when
you've tried and failed I mean I I wrote
a script actually for a TV show that I
loved but I actually never was able to
get it to the TV show in time but I
watched this show I have them all on DVD
and I wrote this script and I thought it
was really really good and it opened
fantastic with this fire bearing down on
Smallville
and super boy putting it out what and it
was all put together by Lex swear to God
one of these days I'm going to have to
get get you the script please yeah
because I'd written for a Sci-Fi show
before uh for
UPN before it became CW called seven
days the time travel show um but no I
loved Smallville and I have to say you
were all you thank you you and your dad
best two actors he he made better he
made me a better actor fantastic thank
you never missed it never missed an
episode no no it's it's absolutely true
that's why it's so cool that I'm got to
know you as a friend and I'm sitting
here today because you Chris and I would
never miss Smallville we just loved it I
love that it was fantastic it's just so
itch I love it I get little like stop
stop I know there were certain episodes
cuz I wrote when I wrote for seven days
you know like in the middle of the
Season you just there's a couple of what
I used to call throwaway episodes but
some of the episodes are Smallville some
of them were I always say that there's
some that are like we're we're doing a
rewatch podcast now and it's like some
of the episodes I'm like okay this is
the show that I'm proud to be on I mean
there were some really great ones oh
when P Ken is being buried oh yeah oh
when the snow and then the black and
white don't go there cuz people no no
people have watched no it is but anyway
back to you but best Lex Luther ever
thank you thank you I I I appreciate
that I I really do James gun are you
listening he's listened and he's I love
him but um now
I want to tap in just a little
bit now some of the people you've met
like who would you
call friends that you could text of the
big 80s bands that we love like what are
what are some of the people that you
could you could text and they would
respond um John Taylor from Duran y
Simon obviously Terry Terry and I Terry
nun yeah she played uh last last night
in Perth Australia so I texted her again
on Thursday and I said hope you're not
flying in coach cuz it is so long plus
Perth is another 5 hours after done that
but Terry nun lead singer of Berlin one
of the most beautiful people inside out
human beings you know if you don't know
her take my breath away and they have
loads of songs writing on the Metro I
love the Metro like so many songs but
you how long did you guys date about
year and a half a year and a half and it
was intense oh well I asked her to marry
me after 6 months and what' you say she
said yes but not right now and then we
broke up on the night she asked me to
marry
her and it it was something not good no
and there we actually have a biopic in
development right now uh about that one
chapter in uh World in my eyes the
chapter called No More Words in your
book and uh but of course um everything
slammed to a Halle in May why uh there
was somebody called the writer strike oh
no no no I don't mean I I didn't mean
that I mean why did why did your
relationship with Terry suddenly stop I
was cheating you were and you admit that
openly in the book uh oh very openly I I
was as my wife said when she read the
book because I said to her I've got to
be completely honest about everything in
here uh she said oh no go ahead
everyone's got a pass don't worry and
then Christa read the book she's like oh
my God you are such a manhor and I said
yeah I was and I I was so in love with
Terry I mean she literally did take my
breath away every time I saw her but
when she went on tour I was you know the
hot DJ in town kind of thing right and
there was so many women um someone I
work with used to say when you're a DJ
the moment you put your lips against a a
microphone on a popular radio station
you change and become Brad p
you know and and back then especially
yeah because that was the only way you
got your music and so I mean I was
screwing around all the time but the
moment Terry came back there was not
another wasn't another person in the
world never mind another woman in the
world but she found
out she showed up at a gig of mine and I
was with uh my co-host from mv3 and we
were having a an affair and I was DJing
and a guy six foot tall guy in pink
spandex with wings on his back came down
to the club and he goes hello we've got
a message and I said oh look singing
telegram I I guess uh who's the message
for and I'm doing this on the mic you
know might make it fun for everybody oh
boy and he goes it's for you and I went
okay what is it and he goes no it's
upstairs and so I went okay cuz this
club called Mr Jays underneath a Chinese
restaurant and and so I said okay hot
hotti is going to play the music for a
little bit the club DJ uh I'm going
upstairs anyone want to come and so
about 100 people came upstairs and we go
into the parking lot of um Mr Jay's in
El Monte and it was something that Terry
had planned to do two weeks before when
she'd got back for three days off tour
and we went to see Sparks together at
the Hollywood ball at the uh Greek
Theater but she couldn't get permission
for for what she wanted to do because of
where it it is but in Al Monte they have
a private airport right next door so you
can use planes there you can't just fly
over the Greek right and so um I said to
the singing telegram okay what's the
message and as I'm saying that Karen's
got her arm around me and kiss giving me
kisses and stuff like that and he goes
message is up there and so I look up and
there's a plane that's just flying
around Mr Jays in the big parking lot
and it's Sky riding across its
wings I'm ready to jump marry me
Terry and I went just tell me she's not
here he goes she's over there and I look
and I see Terry's car and the door is
opening and Terry is wearing the wedding
dress that she was wearing in the
Masquerade
video and she's halfway out the car and
sees Karen kissing
me and suddenly realizes oh my God you
know all the times I've been with Karen
and Terry slammed the door shut and I
just ran over to her car and held onto
the handle of the the car and I'm
screaming I love you I love you I'm so
sorry I love you and she just drove off
with tears in her eyes and the plane
just kept flying over saying I'm ready
to jump marry me and the crowd's going
was that Terry nun and and you're numb
your whole body I I just gra I just said
to Peter was with me as well take Karen
home now and we had a limo because I was
doing the mornings and uh the club went
till midnight so I could sleep in the
car and he goes how you get home I said
I'll find a way I'll find a way and they
so Terry goes off one way the limo goes
off the other and the plane is just
making fun of me by just flying around
saying I'm ready to marry you did you
ever talk to her again not not for 7
years and the next time I talked to her
I and this part's not in the book
actually next time I talked to her was
on a Saturday uh and it was I was doing
my shift on krock and it was I think
probably August and I was in shorts tank
top baseball hat unshaven and the the
phone rings it wasn't the hotline she
didn't know the hotline at that time she
was out of music she hadn't she quit the
band in ' 86 and went through a bad bad
period and uh she called me up on the
request line I go hi she goes it's Terry
and I went oh my God Terry how are you
how are you she goes I'm great uh um I
want to see you today and I
said where when and she goes any as soon
as you get off the air and I said where
do you want me to meet me and she said
in Beverly Hills the place is a Jag
dealership now it used to be a
restaurant and I said okay I'll I'll go
home and change he said no come come as
you are I said I can't come as I am I'm
I mean can't go go to a restaurant she
goes it's not just a restaurant it's my
wedding I was like oh my God okay and
she I said but I'm I'm in shorts and a
tank top and a baseball hat and she said
I don't care I want you at my wedding
and so I drove to Beverly Hills and went
to her
wedding in in shorts and a baseball hat
did you
cry I did and her mother and I danced
and she said to me we always hoped it
would be
you and it's not the it's not the
husband she's with now right it was her
first husband it only lasted about 18
months but uh it
was it was hard and then she told me a
few things and I apologized to her and
for the
next probably 10 years every time I
would see her I would say I am so sorry
I am so [__] sorry for what I did to
you cuz what I did was inexcusable but
it it looks as though you know it takes
a lot of guts to writing a book saying I
was a Manor I did this I was and I
didn't like what I did but I found my
way yeah and I knew I was wrong I knew
when I was doing it you didn't deny I
was wrong no but it was little head was
thinking more than big head you know and
it was it was
really it was awful what I did to her
awful but uh we'll we'll see you know I
mean it there you know talking about the
biopic and they really want to get into
that chapter but she went through a bad
period and you know I really screwed up
one of the most beautiful women on the
planet for a number of years and that I
can't forgive myself for I can forgive
myself for losing her and for her losing
me but I can't forgive myself for
putting her in such a bad position
mentally you know I know cuz she well
you know what she forgives you yeah she
does but but you don't forgive yourself
yeah no not for that no yeah I don't she
was she's a great great human being a
great she is human being did you ever go
through Depression Did you ever you know
we talk about that but did you ever go
through like uh Hard Times where you
need to see a psychiatrist or talk to
them about you know your issues and
because we talk about mental health here
a lot but did you ever have to deal with
that or did you ever no I I didn't I had
one very short bout very short couple of
hours but put a gun against my head in
in that very short period of time and
that was when I ended up marrying
Karen and it was a good marriage but not
a not a passionate one if you know what
I mean right and um I came home one day
and there was no note no nothing but
some of her clothes were gone and the
house felt different and so I made uh
but three calls and on the third call I
got her sister and she said Karen's um
in Santa Barbra with her mother doesn't
want to speak to you for a week she
wants to get her head together we never
argued it was out of the blue it would
be like you and me on stage at the
palace and suddenly me turning around
and hitting you with a baseball bat
saying [__] off yeah [__] off and you
like who where hey hey hang on what
happened I had no clue what caused
anything and this just hit you hard it
hit me so hard and I called a couple of
other people I called Peter got his
machine there was no one I could talk to
at the time and I was just spinning I
mean literally almost like vertigo and
I'd bought a shotgun for Karen to have
it as protection in the house because I
was doing gigs people knew when I was
gone because I advertise on the radio
right and I'm not into guns I'm not a
big gun person but I figured a shotgun
you don't have to aim it and it makes a
lot of noise so if someone did break in
could just you know pull the trigger and
point it roughly in the direction and um
maybe make contact with a couple of the
pallets but the noise would but you got
that dark that that dark that I got the
gun and put it against my head were you
really thinking I was going to pull pull
the trigger but my I had a dog a little
dog called Angel and Angel lay on my
foot and started to howl like she knew
what was going on and I would I thought
if I kill myself what happens to angel
is she going to starve to death maybe I
should put some food down so I Put the
gun down first and then I thought what
the [__] am I doing how would my
mom handle this you know she's lost Dad
how would she devastated yeah and and
that was like that was the darkest I've
ever been and I've never been there
before and never been there since but
for that 2 to three hours it was wow
didn't like it obviously yeah
understatement of the year I didn't like
it yeah you know well you should have
seen someone a therapist and talk I
didn't need to afterwards really no I
didn't need to I've I mean I would go to
a therapist I mean a lot of people do
and and get reward from it but I'm I've
never been in that position I thought I
I can't get through this myself um and
if I if I had those thoughts again I
would definitely go to a therapist I I
would 100% when Karen and I got back
together uh just over a week later we
went to a a therapist together a
marriage therapist we went two times and
she said I don't see anything wrong with
you as a couple you know you don't argue
you seem to really relate to each other
but something inside was not clicking
with us I know about that I know about
being in something where you're like
this person's great and she's this and
that and I everything should lead you to
think that everything's fine and this is
but then there are a few things that you
just don't feel or you're not feeling or
you're just like you can't force it and
there's no Rhyme or Reason it's just a
feeling that you're just like you can't
make something work that really just
ultimately isn't there it's missing if
if you're missing a big component you
know the smallest thing that seems so
trivial could be that's it all these
other little things I could deal with
but this one is just like I just I I
know I know what you're saying I know
that I know the feeling and I'm being
fortunate with Christa we've never had
that we we have the same kind of
relationship that I had with Karen where
we we hardly ever argue I mean might say
h honey come on do this oh yeah you're
right or you're wrong or whatever but we
never get into arguments but um I don't
know what triggered it with Karen I've
got ideas what might have triggered it
but it's a shame it's I'm glad you
didn't do it that day so was the angel
at the time Angel was great dog too but
listen I mean I could talk to you
forever and I you know um and I want you
to come back because this is you have so
many stories it's just like I could just
sit here and listen to you for days but
the book rolled in my eyes you also have
the other book
what is it tell me okay I have you have
seven books lock down interviews yeah I
have three non-fiction right and then
four novels and I'm writing my fifth
novel right now I have lockdown
interviews which were done during coid
when the bands had nothing to do but
talk like with Boy George six hours we
chatted you know so I mean it just just
it was incredible because normally when
you get a band you have 15 minutes
because they got Access Hollywood Wai
Got Deep yeah so it was it was Fant
fantastic um not Co but the the the
lockdown and then the unlocked
interviews were bands raring to go and
get back out on the road like Blondie
and Roxy Music and people like that
that's then the unlocked and then uh the
four novels one of them is alternate
history uh but one is 2,000 years ago a
group of Romans survive a Atlantic
hurricane but are washed up on this
strange Shore which is actually North
Carolina but you can't say that in the
book CU it wasn't North Carolina and
they they encounter a group of Native
Americans who weren't Native Americans
they were natives at the time and these
45 of the most hardened Warriors in the
world learn a different way a way of
peace and a way of love until a great
evil comes and then the Romans have to
decide do we go try and go back to Rome
or do we stand and fight Jesus how do
you and it's uh it's really cool your
mind just that's the thing you're so
creative you're just you're doing what
you love last
question top five favorite bands of all
time even gun to your head I sorry about
that okay no no no no Chris Chris and I
not a gun to your head we play this game
all the time all right and now listen
you I know you have you're friends with
a lot of these guys but so you got to
really in Your Heart of Heart top five
bands okay top five bands I bet I can
get one of them okay
depes mode tied at number one Smiths who
who is tied with thees mode you think
the Smiths no no uh depesh
mode Durand Duram Beatles Beatles oh be
all right and greatest song from The
Beatles for me she's leaving home that
is a three minute movie if you listen to
the lyrics of that write down it's a
movie most incredible and the way the
chorus changes from she's leaving home
to she's having
fun just brilliant the pesh mode Beatles
Beatles um it's got to be morsy or Smith
I'm sure Tears for Fears oh I love tears
I just saw him at the ball great yeah
uh Sergio Mendes
ah my alltime favorite song that Christ
is going to play at my wake in about 112
years time is
masanada it it's Brazilian I know it
yeah oh my gosh what a song it's just
and what's the last one the last one
is
maybe now Duran Duran dur having
spent seen them recently a number of
times in concert and realizing what an
incredible body of work they have and I
made a mistake a few years back when I
was uh actually having drinks with Simon
We were talking about uh you know radio
and touring and all different kinds of
things and I went God you're so lucky to
have so many songs and he looked at me
he goes has nothing to do with luck and
he he was right he was right it was it
was work you know I mean they put it
together I because so many bands would
kill to have that many songs it's uh
incredible Richard this has been awesome
to me I I just so much Insight it's just
like I know little things about you and
your talent and this but I didn't know a
lot of these stories and how all these
things came together and there's so much
more to talk about get the book World in
my eyes he has so many other books it's
so interesting if you love the 80s if
you love music he knows so much about
music and your life is so interesting
and I'm so happy for you and and Christa
and that you found your person and um
and and thank you for being a friend and
coming here today oh anytime I'll come
back and next time I won't talk so much
I'll no I like it it helps me it's easy
for me cool all right you're the best
thanks yeah he uh he opens up there
wasn't he doesn't really hold back you
know and I and his stories are really
interesting and and fun and it just puts
me I love that era I love hearing about
does he know these people are you know
meeting Duran Duran or going out with
beautiful Terry nun from Berlin and uh
it was just uh it was fun for me it
really was and I hope it's fun for you
any 80s folks out there um again and
patreon.com inside of you join today
support the podcast I will send you a
message uh we need you to support the
podcast and tovil podcast uh that's
patreon.com talk if you want to support
both podcasts more so mine um but thank
you for listening today uh one of the
perks of being a patron is you get your
your name the top tiers get their name
shouted out every month every week every
week 50 episodes a week because I think
we do 50 maybe we do 51 not
sure but Ryan let's do it okay here the
shout outs to the top tier patrons Nancy
Davis oh do them in a spooky voice you
should do all your spooky voices
Christen little Isa
you your
turn Jill e Brian H Nico
p Robert B Jason W Sophie M Raj C Josh
D Jennifer N Stacy L Jamal F you're New
Yorker
now New Yorker Janelle F give me a taxi
a o Janelle
B Ashley Ryan a o Mike E also Jason put
some little creep creepy Halloween music
over this will'll be funner just
likeon supro 99 more San Diego M Chad W
lean P Badd s binda n Dave H hello Dave
Hall shill G Brad d r h Tabitha T this
is Dracula it is I see that it's very
good Tom n Talia M bet d ran C well let
me tell you about Cory k it's like
Stallone doing a
vampire Dev Nexon Michelle a Jeremy C
Brandy D Joanie B Joey em Eugene and Ali
That's Italian now well Dracula's
vaguely he's kind of from Romanian
actually that's true not Italian Cory
Angela F meles
christines Eric Eric
H Shane R Andrew M
I was trying to that was good I saw you
know uh the show what we do in the
shadows for nandor
nandor understand you want to be a
vampire
yeah Andrew M am or Jin B Kevin e
Stephanie K jorel Jam J lean J
gioo Luna R mik Stone Ed stay wild Moon
child Brian L Kendall l k c Jessica B
Kyle F Marisol P Kaye J Brian a Ashley F
Maran Louise L Romeo the band Frank B
gen that is close it
up Nikki L April M A April RM yeah Randy
R Randy
s deran
jdw Oro P Ginger Insomniac Rachel to the
L hello L
LA Melissa H NES W Stephanie and even
Charlene a and don't
forget
Don
G all right that is all our top tier
patrons but we love you all thank you
for listening I hope you come back next
week because this accent could have
pissed you off more than I could
possibly
imagine but it won't be back next week I
promise you that thank you Bryce and
Ryan and Jason nelin for their wonderful
editing and putting up with my horeshit
all the time I love you from the bottom
of my
heart Michael Rose mom here from the
Hollywood Hills in California I also
have a heart I also have
a on
Jesus I'm right I'm also here little
wave to the camera we love you guys be
good to
[Music]
yourself